thank you all for coming on short notice  and a certainly happy new year welcome  back it's good to be back we're gonna  kick 20-19 off just slightly differently  and I'd like to welcome a very special  guest for an appearance here in the  briefing room our very great president  Donald J Trump  he's happy new year happy New Year to  everybody well thank you very much I  appreciate that thank you I just want to  start off by congratulating Nancy Pelosi  on being elected Speaker of the House  it's a very very great achievement and  hopefully we're going to work together  and we're gonna get lots of things done  like infrastructure and so much more no  they want to do that very badly so do I  so hopefully we're gonna have a lot of  things that we can get done together and  I think it's actually going to work out  I think it'll be a little bit different  than a lot of people are thinking so I  congratulate Nancy tremendous tremendous  achievement